[Musique]
l'étang à faire un truc et tout le monde
va jouer là dedans guitare on va faire
le dilemme du poste auquel on proposait
deux personnages à chaque fois des
personnages qui ont marqué votre vie
d'accord à chaque fois vous devant
choisir l'un des deux d'accord attention
il n'y a pas d'eau je sais pas c'est
qu'il y en a un que je garde son biais
elle obligée attention premier jul
premier dilemme jul regarder toulouse
soprano vous avez fait un duo avec les
deux ça les dérange avec jul et pas
cette fois avec soprano - manutan
ouais c'est ça je te [ __ ] je te fous
dans la mer des méga carrément non après
j'aurais été paré mois dans l'année on
avait des douleurs
alors non je dirais plaisir et sopra
parce qu'on se connaît depuis longtemps
et voilà la carrière quoi d'accord ils
vous aiment les deux me voilà tout avait
elle a choisi sopra musicaux aux
victoires de la musique là franchement
ouais donc à nrj music awards s'est auto
comprend j'aurais fait pareil
voilà attention ça peut être
complètement autre chose la regarde
comme en ce moment en string je dis oui
tu préfères quoi les mecs qui préfère
quand c'est couvert en fait d'accord bah
t'as raison merci cas ça c'était
difficile de choisir entre les deux là
là alors assez dur alors franchement
au-delà de tous points de vue politiques
n'ont pas de politique c'est comme ça
comment tu les revoilà jeu j'aime bien
aujourd'hui l'ancien palois mais voilà
il est surtout les deux sympa ouais côte
à ce jour et il me paraît sympa sont
sympathiques tous les deux balles ou du
maître gims où straw bailly avait laissé
va bien une star fait oui alors maître
gims ou stromae on rappelle games a
coécrit votre dernier album stromae a
participé aussi j'ai droit devant est
dit que si je veux pas tout seul quoi
dans la fosse choisir n'en faut choisir
faut choisir et c'est jure c'est mon ami
et allaoui m si votre avis stromae
maestro en plus de monstres aux mailles
on est sûr qu'il nous regarde
maitre gims je sais qu'il nous regarde
souvent sinon c'est notre pote aussi on
le kiffe mais c'est quoi la tasse on ne
sortira pas dit si je vais choisir parce
que c'est mon ami je vais dire gims
parce que c'est mon ami vraiment c'est
mon ami dans l'intimité voilà est-ce
qu'on aille au seae mais on se connaît
depuis moins longtemps et c'est vrai que
j'aime c'est vrai mes proches je crois
tu prends tu prends gims ouais bon bah
très bien et zita quand même
[Applaudissements]